[Music]
taking in the sights of Sydney on the
Royal tour
King Charles back when he was Prince
popular but not enough to get his head
now that he is King on Australia's new
five dollar note in this Royal redesign
the monarchy is out
and Indigenous culture is in the Central
Bank says the new note will honor the
history of the first Australians a
symbolic change after the death of Queen
Elizabeth
she graced Sydney's opera house but will
no longer Grace its five dollar bill no
Royal will I think the queen is amazing
and so we should keep her on a in like
loving memory of her
um maybe the king could go on another
note I think that's a really great idea
to connect back to Australia's history
rather than the white history of
Australia and that history and identity
of colonial Britain of white Australia
is being challenged there are heated
awkward conversations to come
sometimes such stories can feel
uncomfortable for those whose stories
they are and for those who hear them
but understanding the past enables us to
better share the present
and the future
a future with or without the monarchy
Australia has not decided but there is a
growing sense that a reckoning on a
republic is coming Nicole Johnston Sky
News Sydney